très direction présent la tunisie où
l'on peine toujours à sortir de la crise
politique le pays est sans gouvernement
depuis presque deux mois après le coup
de force du président kaïs saïd qui
décrète d'ailleurs ce soir plusieurs
dispositions pour réguler l'exercice des
pouvoirs législatif et exécutif et
pouvoirs de la présidence sont
renforcées au détriment du gouvernement
du côté de l'opposition des voix
s'élèvent le parti ennahdha mettant en
garde contre un démantèlement de l'état
des précisions de notre correspondant à
tunis bfm chez
ennahda vent debout contre le président
kaïs ça y est comme de nombreux partis
de l'opposition est la formation
politique conduite par rached ghannouchi
n'a pas tardé à réagir à la locution
surprise du président ça y est une prise
de parole présidentielle qui se voulait
ferme et directives à destination de ses
principaux opposants quand pour leur
rappeler qu'ils comptent bien poursuivre
son opération main propre principale
annonce le maintien des mesures
exceptionnelles entrée en vigueur le 25
juillet dernier et l'adoption d'une
nouvelle loi électorale
il n'en fallait pas plus pour raviver la
colère de l'opposition pour ennahdha le
maintien des mesures exceptionnelles et
l'absence de gouvernement légitime ne
font qu'aggraver la situation politique
et économique du pays et risque
d'entraîner un démantèlement de l'état
je vous propose de les écouter
le président kaïs ça y est depuis sa
décision du 25 juillet dernier continue
d'affirmer qu'il travaill ait agi dans
le cadre de la légitimité de la
constitution mais ce qui la fait
constitue une grave infraction à la
constitution lors de son dernier
discours à sidi bouzid nous avons
assisté à un changement de ton son
conseiller spécial a confirmé à
plusieurs reprises que le président
s'apprêtait à abolir la constitution
mais face à la réaction des partis et de
la société civile le président s'est
rétracté en annonçant qu'il amenderait
la constitution plutôt que de l'annuler
il a annoncé à sidi bouzid qu'il
adopterait des dispositions transitoires
ce qui constitue un contournement de la
constitution en d'autres termes il ne
souhaite conserver qu'une partie de la
constitution et abandonner le reste y
compris les chapitres législatif
exécutif jeudi r et ce qui concerne la
gouvernance locale
nous considérons qu'il s'agit d'une
dérogation à la légitimité et une
abolition de la constitution il est
conscient que le pays est en danger
raison pour laquelle il veut tout
changer cela ne peut se faire sans
dialogue ni participation de tous les
partis politiques nous n'avons pas
hésité à qualifier le coup de force du
25 juillet de coup d'état dès les
premières minutes car le président de la
république s'est retourné contre le
premier ministre en le limogeant sans
réponse constitutionnel puis il a gelé
le président du parlement et toute
l'institution législative et violé
gravement la constitution
ceci bien sûr a été fait par la force il
ne s'agit pas d'un coup d'état militaire
classique le président s'est toujours
retourner contre les institutions grâce
au pouvoir que lui octroie la
constitution en tant que commandant en
chef des forces armées malgré les
inquiétudes de la population et les
attaques de l'opposition le président
saleh semble déterminée à poursuivre son
coup de force nouvelle loi électorale
modification de la constitution encore
élections législatives anticipées
l'agenda de l'homme fort de la tunisie
demeure flou au grand dam des magistrats
avocats société civile partis
d'opposition et qui craignent une dérive
autoritaire kaïs ayed qui a déclaré
lundi qu'un nouveau chef du gouvernement
sera bientôt annoncée continue néanmoins
de jouir du soutien d'une large partie
de la population